Traduttore: Eleonora Cavallo
Revisore: Martina Cavallo
Tecnologia.
Noi siamo circondati dalla tecnologia.
Il computer è diventato
il nostro compagno di viaggio,
il cellulare la nostra appendice,
utilizziamo automobili ipertecnologiche.
Se dobbiamo andare da qualche parte,
digitiamo l'indirizzo
sul cellulare o sul navigatore
perché sappiamo che il GPS ci porterà
esattamente dove vogliamo arrivare.
Se dobbiamo fare un controllo
e andiamo in ospedale,
non ci preoccupiamo
se ci distendono sul lettino
e ci infilano in un tunnel
per fare una TAC,
o una risonanza magnetica,
o un esame di medicina nucleare.
Tecnologia.
Come ci siamo arrivati?
La tecnologia ci riempie di immagini.
Noi viviamo di immagini,
siamo bombardati di immagini,
fissiamo le idee con le immagini,
sviluppiamo i concetti con le immagini.
Il 2016 è l'anno
delle onde gravitazionali.
L'infinitamente grande.
Chi di noi non ha mai visto
le bellissime immagini, le fotografie,
del telescopio Hubble,
che ci mostra
le profondità dell'universo?
Sono immagini che ci affascinano
perché ci parlano di chi siamo,
da dove veniamo, dove andiamo.
L'infinitamente grande.
Nel 2012 tutti abbiamo imparato
che cos'è il bosone di Higgs
e abbiamo visto le immagini
dell'infinitamente piccolo,
degli acceleratori di particelle come LHC,
dove gli esperimenti scattano
40 milioni di fotografie al secondo
con decine di miliardi di pixel,
per farci vedere cosa succede
quando due protoni si scontrano
e producono un bosone di Higgs.
L'infinitamente piccolo.
E poi l'uomo.
Il 23 dicembre 1895
il rettore di un'università tedesca
pubblica la prima radiografia
della storia,
la radiografia della mano di sua moglie.
Il 23 dicembre 1895
nasce la medicina moderna.
Fino ad allora per guardarvi nella pancia,
vi aprivano la pancia;
da quella data vi fanno una radiografia.
In 70 anni siamo stati capaci
di far girare un tubo a raggi X
tutto intorno al paziente
per farlo in tante fettine,
che messe insieme ci fanno vedere
l'interno del suo corpo
come se fosse aperto di fronte a noi.
La TAC.
Qualche anno dopo il 1895,
siamo negli anni '30-'40, più o meno,
nasce un altro ramo
della medicina diagnostica:
la medicina nucleare.
Quel ramo della diagnostica
che vuole vedere
come funziona il vostro corpo
e non come è fatto.
Abbiamo trasformato i pazienti
in sorgenti radioattive
per scoprire gli hotspot,
cioè quelle zone particolarmente attive
che possono essere indice
di qualcosa che non va.
L'immagine che vedete
alle mie spalle non è fantasia,
è l'immagine di un paziente
a cui abbiamo fatto una TAC
e un esame di medicina nucleare,
una tomografia a emissione di positroni.
Tecnologia e immagini.
Come ci siamo arrivati?
Come siamo arrivati
a questo livello di sviluppo?
Abbiamo osservato la Natura,
abbiamo capito come funziona
e l'abbiamo usata.
Quali occhiali abbiamo dovuto costruire
per riuscire a osservare
l'infinitamente grande,
l'infinitamente piccolo,
tutto quello che ci circonda
e anche quello che sta dentro di noi?
Gli occhiali che abbiamo costruito,
e continueremo a costruire,
per osservare la Natura si chiamano
"rivelatori di particelle".
Non ho sbagliato il termine.
Il "rilevatore" è la persona
che vi telefona
per sapere quante volte
bevete il latte in una settimana.
"Rivelatore" ha lo stesso significato
della parola inglese "detector",
che deriva dal latino "detegere":
togliere il coperchio, scoperchiare,
togliere la coperta, togliere il lenzuolo.
I rivelatori ci fanno togliere il velo
alla Natura per capire come funziona.
Io sono un fisico che sviluppa
rivelatori di particelle.
La cosa incredibile
è che per osservare
l'infinitamente grande,
l'infinitamente piccolo
e tutto quello che ci circonda,
si usano gli stessi rivelatori,
basati sugli stessi princìpi.
Ne esistono di incredibilmente diversi.
Ne esistono grandi
come l'unghia del mio dito mignolo,
come quelli che stanno
nei vostri cellulari quando fate una foto
o come quelli che sono arrivati
con i robottini su Marte
per andare a vedere
di cosa sono fatte le rocce di Marte.
Ne esistono di un po' più grandi,
come quelli che ho messo
sul satellite AGILE,
che sta girando a 500 km di altezza.
Piastrelline di 10x10 cm
che hanno riempito un cubo di 1 m di lato.
Ne esistono di decisamente grandi,
come quelli per studiare
l'infinitamente piccolo,
come quelli di LHC.
CMS pesa 7.000 tonnellate,
ATLAS è 20x20x30 metri cubi.
Sembra incredibile
ma per studiare l'infinitamente piccolo
costruiamo delle cose
che sono sempre più grandi
e sempre più complesse.
Poi ne esistono
di decisamente extra large.
Tutti quelli che servono
per studiare le particelle rare
che arrivano
dalle profondità dell'universo
o quelle particolarmente elusive.
Ognuno di noi ogni secondo è attraversato
da svariati miliardi di neutrini
e non se ne accorge.
Chi vuole studiare i neutrini ha bisogno
di grandi quantità di materiali.
Allora usa l'inter-atmosfera terrestre,
o riempie di acqua una miniera,
o utilizza la luce che i neutrini emettono
quando interagiscono con l'acqua del mare.
Rivelatori di particelle:
i nostri occhiali.
Ma non basta,
perché, se ci pensate, i rivelatori
non ci fanno vedere un fenomeno,
ci fanno vedere un prodotto.
Voi non vedete le mie corde vocali,
voi sentite il suono che emettono.
Noi non vediamo
i nuclei del sole che fondono,
vediamo la luce che deriva
da quella fusione.
Non vediamo due protoni
che si scontrano a LHC,
vediamo le decine di milioni
di canali di elettronica che si accendono
e ci dicono che cosa è successo
quando i due protoni si sono scontrati.
I rivelatori di particelle
ci fanno vedere un prodotto,
dal prodotto dobbiamo dedurre il fenomeno.
Lo dobbiamo inquadrare
in una teoria e fare previsioni,
perché se la teoria non fa previsioni
rimane un bel volo della mente.
Verificare le previsioni,
se funzionano, bene,
altrimenti ricominciamo da capo.
Questa è stata la nostra ricetta vincente.
È stato mettere insieme l'osservazione
che facciamo con i rivelatori
con l'inquadramento in una teoria,
che facciamo con la nostra intuizione
e la nostra creatività.
E abbiamo raccontato la Natura.
Volete degli esempi?
Tutti conosciamo il Big Bang.
Tutti sappiamo che 13,7 miliardi
di anni fa c'è stato uno "scoppio",
in cui una quantità immensa di energia
a una temperatura elevatissima
di 10 alla 32 °K
si è trasformata in materia.
Prima i costituenti
delle particelle elementari,
poi le particelle elementari.
I protoni sono nati un microsecondo
dopo il Big Bang, 10 alla -6 secondi.
Noi e tutto quello che ci circonda
siamo fatti di quei protoni lì,
noi siamo fatti dei protoni del Big Bang.
Poi tutte le altre particelle elementari:
atomi, molecole e gli elementi
via via fino a 13,7 miliardi di anni dopo.
L'universo come ce l'ha fatto conoscere
il telescopio Hubble;
decisamente più freddino
rispetto a quando è nato.
Questa è una bellissima teoria,
ma le teorie hanno bisogno di verifiche.
Questa teoria ha avuto
tantissime verifiche;
io ve ne racconto una che secondo me
è importantissima ed è fantastica.
Negli anni '50 in New Jersey, negli USA,
è stata costruita un'antenna
che si chiamava Holmdel Antenna,
per un progetto di telecomunicazioni.
Stiamo parlando di telecomunicazioni,
onde radio, le conosciamo tutti.
Tutti sappiamo cos'è un'antenna radio.
Il progetto si chiamava Echo,
c'erano dei satelliti che comunicavano.
Quando il progetto si completa,
il Bell Telephone Labs e due fisici,
Robert Wilson e Arno Penzias,
decidono di modificare l'antenna
per captare le onde radio,
sempre di onde radio si tratta,
dalle profondità della Via Lattea.
Nel 1964 la accendono,
la girano in tutte le direzioni
e continuano a sentire
un fastidioso ticchettio.
A quel punto prendono il telefono
e chiamano Princeton,
dove c'era uno dei maggiori teorici
della teoria del Big Bang, Robert Dickie.
Lui risponde, mette giù il telefono,
si gira verso i collaboratori e dice:
"Ci hanno battuti sul tempo",
prende la macchina e li raggiunge.
Robert Wilson e Arno Penzias
avevano scoperto
la radiazione cosmica di fondo.
Quando l'universo ha compiuto
380 mila anni, anno più anno meno,
è diventato trasparente.
A quel punto la luce è potuta uscire.
La radiazione cosmica di fondo
è la candelina
che l'universo ha soffiato
quando ha compiuto 380 mila anni,
13,7 miliardi di anni fa.
La radiazione cosmica di fondo è isotropa,
uniforme in tutte le direzioni.
Pensate a un telo teso.
In realtà ha
delle piccolissime fluttuazioni.
L'immagine che vedete
alle mie spalle, appena arriva,
è l'immagine raccolta
dal satellite WMAP della NASA.
I puntini gialli e rossi
sono le fluttuazioni
della radiazione cosmica di fondo.
I puntini gialli e rossi sono i semini
delle stelle e delle galassie di oggi.
Stiamo parlando di onde radio,
non parliamo di cose stratosferiche.
Gli occhiali che abbiamo
costruito per misurarle
ci permettono di leggere un libro
di 13,7 miliardi di anni fa.
Incredibile!
All'inizio del 1900
i fisici entrano in crisi,
perché non riescono a capire
come luce e materia possono parlarsi.
La luce è un'onda che pervade
tutto lo spazio infinitamente.
La materia è fatta di atomi
che sono corpuscoli infinitamente piccoli.
Come fa questa onda a interagire
istantaneamente con gli elettroni
che stanno negli atomi della mia retina
e questo succede perché io vedo.
Tra l'altro gli occhi sono l'esempio
più antico del rivelatore di particelle,
realizzato in miliardi di coppie
più o meno funzionanti.
Allora loro cosa capiscono?
Le osservazioni erano corrette,
ma l'interpretazione no.
È il binomio la vittoria,
la ricetta vincente.
Capiscono che le osservazioni
sono corrette e allora dicono:
vuole dire che quando ci spostiamo
verso il micromondo,
l'infinitamente piccolo,
le leggi che abbiamo scritto
per inquadrare quello che osserviamo
in ciò che ci circonda
non funzionano più tanto bene,
dobbiamo cambiarle.
Perché nel micromondo
le onde sono particelle
e le particelle sono onde.
Pensate la difficoltà
dal punto di vista dell'intuizione,
ben prima di formalizzare,
di immaginare una cosa del genere.
Le onde sono particelle
e le particelle sono onde.
Da qui nasce tutta la nostra tecnologia.
L'aver pensato questo
e poi averlo formalizzato
e aver capito che la Natura
veramente funziona così
ci ha portato a sviluppare
occhiali sempre più potenti.
Volete un esempio?
Tutti voi avete utilizzato
il microscopio ottico:
una sorgente luminosa,
il campione e una lente.
E vi guardate il vostro bel campione
in due dimensioni.
Ma se invece della sorgente luminosa
io utilizzo gli elettroni,
li strappo dagli atomi come delle biglie,
perché tanto biglie sono;
li accelero con una differenza
di potenziale, perché tanto biglie sono;
e poi li mando a sbattere
contro il campione.
Quando arrivano lì,
ci arrivano con un'energia
per cui si comportano
come un fascio di luce
con una lunghezza d'onda
molto più piccola della luce visibile.
E allora vuole dire
che vedo campioni più piccoli.
Ma rimangono pur sempre
delle biglie cariche.
E allora vuole dire che con facilità
posso anche fare una scansione
e ottenere la terza dimensione.
Questo è il principio su cui si basa
il microscopio elettronico a scansione.
Le immagini che produce sono come quella
che vedete alle mie spalle,
che è l'immagine della bocca di una larva.
Occhiali.
Rivelatori di particelle.
Ma la cosa ancora più affascinante
è che i rivelatori
che utilizziamo per vedere gli elettroni
che interagiscono con la bocca della larva
sono gli stessi che stanno
nei cellulari per far le foto,
sono gli stessi che sono andati su Marte,
sono gli stessi che mettiamo nella zona
in cui i protoni si scontrano
per ricostruirne le tracce,
sono gli stessi che ho caricato
sul satellite AGILE
che sta girando a 500 km d'altezza
in orbita equatoriale
osservando le profondità dell'universo.
Come WMAP della NASA,
ma con una lunghezza d'onda diversa:
i raggi gamma.
Pensateci, è come leggere
il libro dell'universo
scritto in un'altra lingua.
Fanno parte della stessa famiglia
di quelli che usiamo per farvi una TAC.
Sono rivelatori che ci permettono
di studiare e conservare il passato.
Nel 1970 è stato scoperto
il papiro di En-Gedi.
Più che un papiro
è un mucchietto di cenere
poco più grande di una moneta.
Assolutamente inutilizzabile.
Non si poteva manipolare,
sarebbe andato in mille pezzetti
e sarebbe stato perso.
È di poche settimane fa la notizia
che un gruppo di ricercatori statunitensi
con un gruppo di ricercatori israeliani
ha deciso di fare una microTAC preclinica
come quelle che si usano in ospedale:
un tubo a raggi X che gira
intorno al mucchietto di cenere
e lo fa in tante fettine.
La stessa cosa si sta facendo in Italia
per i papiri di Ercolano.
Poi hanno applicato un algoritmo
di unwrapping virtuale in 3D
e sono riusciti a leggerlo,
scoprendo che è una copia
del Libro del Levitico.
Anzi, pare che sia la più antica copia
di un libro del Pentateuco
mai trovato in un'arca sacra.
La datazione con il carbonio-14
dice che è del III-IV secolo d.C.
Rivelatori, gli occhiali,
e l'interpretazione che ne diamo
ci hanno permesso di capire
che la Natura è un puzzle molto articolato
con tanti pezzi.
Qualcuno ha intuito il disegno,
qualcuno ha sistemato qualche pezzo,
qualcuno ne ha trovati di nuovi.
Quello che è certo
è che lo scopo finale per chi come me
sviluppa rivelatori di particelle
e per tutti coloro che analizzano
la mole incredibile di dati,
che questi rivelatori raccolgono,
rimane sempre lo stesso
migliorare la vita dell'uomo a 360°.
Lo diceva anche Einstein:
"In mezzo a tutti i vostri diagrammi,
i vostri esperimenti e laboratori,
ricordatevi dell'uomo".
Quello che facciamo, lo facciamo
per il nostro e il vostro futuro.
Quello che facciamo,
lo facciamo per il futuro dell'uomo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)